letzte woche habe ich dieses video
gemacht können wir ewig leben und in
diesem video bin ich mal eben so um 50
jahre gealtert
das haben wir mit einem effekt gemacht
der nennt sich die fake früher habe ich
das schon mal gemacht da habe ich das
ganze mit schminke gemacht aber jetzt
haben wir einfach andere technologische
möglichkeiten
und da ich selber keine expertin dem
thema bin habe ich mir jakob eingeholt
[Musik]
man kennt dich vom kanal breaking lag wo
ich einige male schon aufgetreten bin
früh erkennen kann als leicht unter dem
namen filz physics wir kennen
wir sind gute freunde und treffen so
regelmäßig und erstaunlich ist das erste
mal dass wir richtig nikolov nach dem
kanal machen und du schreibst aktuell
seine doktorarbeit zum thema künstliche
intelligenz genauer der vorbereitung
davon aber ab januar geht es los und ja
es geht um künstlichen intelligenz und
lehrern tatsächlich um youtube-videos
also wir testen künstliche genc an
youtube videos zum thema lernen die
leute damit lernen okay also dass
einiges an erfahrung beim thema und weil
wir keine erfahrung zu dem thema haben
und wir wollten mich halt altern aber
nicht gefragt ob du uns helfen könnte
ist mich zu gibt fällt nicht zu altern
und das haben wir gemacht und es hat
funktioniert ihr meine kommentare
schreiben hobby davon verarscht wurden
ob ihr das geglaubt habt ich denke man
sieht auch einige fehler da drin die man
verbessern kann
aber wir haben das gemacht und es ist
die technik kann jetzt quasi jeder zu
hause bei sich nutzen und andere
gesichter fremden sicht auf sein eigenes
drauf projizieren und das funktioniert
mit conventional networks genau mit cnn
ja also es geht wie du schon sagst also
sie in and social networks die sind
einfach sehr sehr gut um dinge mit
bildern zum also mit mit pixel im
endeffekt und wie die funktionieren ist
also conversion heißt gefaltet und es
geht darum tatsächlich die daten zu
reduzieren also man filtert an irgendwie
zum beispiel gesichtszüge raus und
reduziert das mit dem max penger sind
einfach so durchschnittswerte im
endeffekt von pixeln damit reduziert man
die daten was interessanterweise bei
bildern hilft weil dadurch die merkmale
teilweise klarer sichtbar werden genau
und was hier jetzt speziell ist wir
haben so ein auto in coda heißt das und
das ist also ein encoder und decoder
denkt oder der geht hin und nimmt die
gesichter werden zwei gesichter einmal
personen wie wir das gesicht clown und
einmal von der person wurde ist
draufsetzen und der nimmt diese
gesichter und sozialen werte daraus also
der der nimmt die wichtigsten merkmale
davon macht etwas zahlenwerte reduziert
das hat auch sozusagen wieder und die
liga oder die bauern wieder die sich
daraus zusammen das schöne ist dass wir
dann für die beiden gesichter den
mechanismus dahinter gelernt haben wie
wir darauf die gesichter herstellen und
damit können wir dann was einige sicht
auf das andere gesicht setzen
das war übrigens fun facts mein papa ich
mich gefragt habe ob ich sein gesicht
klauen kann habe ihn gebeten sich ins
studio zu stellen einmal sagen sich von
allen möglichen seiten zu zeigen mit
einem möglichen gesichtsausdrücken ich
habe gefragt ob er einmal 45 grad von
der kamera weg gucken kann in die eine
richtung in andere richtungen so dass
man sein gesicht aus allen möglichen
seiten hat mit einem gesichtsausdrücken
und das haben wir dann trainiert jetzt
250.000 iterationen also unser computer
lief ja mehrere tage lang wäre
nächtelang durch die ganze zeit und hart
trainiert trainiert trainiert und
versucht die gesichter so nah wie
möglich an anzugleichen
am anfang war es noch total blur ii und
man konnte überhaupt nichts erkennen mit
der zeit immer mehr immer näher quasi zu
dem was es dann später geworden ist
und so funktioniert das auch indem
sondern je mehr daten dann hat je mehr
zeit man hat das zu verarbeiten desto
akkurater kannst werden genau es gibt ja
auch ein punkt wo es nicht mehr
weitergeht es gibt sogar also mein mann
kann so ein ober fitting habe dann wird
zu schlechter oder sowas hängt extrem
mit dem mit dem mit dem nord zusammen
aber erst mal kann man sagen das ist ein
bisschen wie im fitnessstudio je mehr du
trainierst desto besser wirst du habe
ich mir sagen lassen dass wir jetzt
keine eigene erfahrung leider mussten
sport machen naja aber zumindest genau
so funktioniert dass das zeit immer
besser wird immer mehr trainiert wird
auf diese gesichter und der fehler wert
weiter runter gehen ja und deswegen ist
auch günstig intelligenz erst in den
letzten 15 jahren maximal so richtig
wieder einen menschen bekommen gab es
eigentlich schon länger das konzept aber
die computer dafür war nicht da es auf
einem kanal in serie muss darum geht
kleine programmieren zu lernen
mehrere teile wo man wirklich schritt
für schritt sieht wie das ganze
funktioniert das verlinkt ich einmal
hier oben falls es euch interessiert und
jetzt machst du auch ein tutorial dazu
wie man diesen dieb feld macht wie man
also quasi sich jedes x-beliebige
gesicht wenn man davon genug daten hat
auf sein eigenes gesicht drauf setzt und
dann so quasi trump oder putin oder
obama in personifiziert ich hab's mal
testweise mit putin gemacht es ganz
interessant weil er bewegt seinen kopf
hin zu werden relativ persönlichkeit ist
ganz interessant aber da kann man das
ganz gut bei sehen wie das funktioniert
genau das zeige ich wie die leute das
selber zu hause machen können so gebe es
ist noch nicht ganz perfekt aber du hast
wahrscheinlich nicht lang genug
trainiert und ich hab ich habe lange
noch trainiert wahrscheinlich und
zweitens das hat total viel mit den
aufnahmen auch zu tun also für die nun
kleiner teil von gesichter setzen also
augen geht gut und geht gut aber haare
zum beispiel da muss man sich etwas
überlegen so die bleiben sie also es
gibt auch ansätze das zu machen aber das
ist halt noch nicht in diesen die presse
was wir dann eben wie kann man das jetzt
erkennen wenn ich bin nicht so ein video
sehe
tja also und als person der man kann auf
jeden fall schon mal darauf achten ob
irgendwelche artefakte da sind die
chronischen also dass das eigentliche
pixel komisch sind das bringt was hat
mich genau das muss man erst mal raus
bekommen genau dass das was springt ist
ein problem was man selber so ein
bisschen versuchen kann es also wie
gesagt das ist ja nur ein kleiner
ausschnitt den dieses die fake betrifft
ja doch ich fürchte ehrlich gesagt dass
das sich noch ändern wird sobald es da
mehr von diesen techniken gibt die das
auch spüren habe und was genau also ich
meine es gibt auch das ehrlich es gibt
sachen
du die das mittlerweile schon können
aber es ist jetzt nicht so dieses
öffentlich zugänglicher zumindest meines
wissens nach nicht ja und du kannst halt
auf diese übergänge achten zum beispiel
wenn du lachst und irgendwie hört hier
aber plötzlich dann diese lachfalten auf
oder sowas oder die bewegungen von von
der haut oder so was passt nicht mit dem
anderen sachen überein und einer der
vielversprechendsten ansätze die ich
kenne
tatsächlich künstliche intelligenz was
da gemacht wurde ist feuer mit feuer
bekämpfen ist es ist eigentlich auch
ganz logisch weil das geht ja darum dass
man sich viele daten anschaut viele
pixel und so und dann kann man da sehen
oder irgendwelche fehler drin sind und
das so also die erkennt artefakte ja
selber quasi hatte und zum beispiel aus
der sachen wie also wie sie jetzt wieder
nur ein kleiner ausschnitt vom gesicht
verwendet was ist wenn irgendwann out
bewegung oder sowas nicht realistisch
weitergeht was die halt gemacht haben
sind die haben originalbilder genommen
und selbst als solche die pag bilder und
haben dann geschaut wo da die
unterschiede sind und die können damit
ziemlich gut erkennen ob es sich um den
dieb fake handelt aber muss auch dazu
sagen wenn jemand das wirklich wirklich
will
tags drauf packt und was weiß ich dann
wird so ein defekt auch irgendwann so
gut das glaube ich auch da natalie
ausgedrückt werden kann
das geht heute schon wirklich behaupten
also da gibt es jetzt ganz ganz
bekanntes beispiel dass obama der wie
trump beleidigt und das ist in dem video
auch nachher gesagt dass das management
ist um auf die pflege aufmerksam zu
machen
aber was ist wenn jetzt jemand nur
diesen kleinen teil aus schneidet obama
kommt beleidigt ich bin mir relativ
sicher dass die tram supporter da nicht
groß recherchen betreiben sondern direkt
sagen was macht er da und den anzeigen
und was weiß ich was verständlicherweise
sieht richtig gut aus es hat mich am
anfang auch total war hätte das geglaubt
total das ist super gruselig und man
also das ganze volk wendet user
ausgegangen der damit der berühmte
persönlichkeiten fragwürdiges material
fragwürdiges material
gepackt hat und das von also kann ich
nicht nachvollziehen dass zu einem
aufschrei geführt hat ok vielen dank
dass uns das alles mal erklärt dass für
eine super spannend ich bin mit dem
ergebnis auch wenn man sehen kann glaube
ich bei uns noch dass es defekt ist
ziemlich zufrieden und fand einen sehr
coolen effekt deswegen danke dir und wir
sehen uns dann weil hier auf dem kanal
weil ich dann auch dabei genau und
wahrscheinlich nächste woche wenn wir
irgendwie essen gehen oder so vielen
dank fürs zuschauen wie immer bleibt
neugierig und jakob natürlich
[Musik]